hey guys don't think I get to see you
and today we are checking out the Google
Clips camera now this little thing was
really interesting when I first saw that
they announced it it's been out for a
little while now if we're gonna test it
out this is an AI camera so basically
you place it around your house and it is
supposed to recognize people that you
would want to take pictures of which
sounds it's super super creepy now that
I'm saying it out loud so when it syncs
to your Google photos it basically uses
machine learning to learn the faces of
your friends and people that you've
taken pictures of so that it knows to
prioritize those people when the camera
sees it it sounds so great
there's no actual internet connection in
the camera itself it only will connect
to the phone that you haven't synced to
so for me of course I'm going to be
singing it to my iPhone and you have to
download the Google clips app and from
there it will take you through the setup
doesn't really do video with audio it
basically is just shooting 15 frames a
second in photos and that'll stitch
those together to create a seven second
video I haven't even unboxed it yet so
let's do that first
[Music]
so this thing definitely isn't
inexpensive it's two hundred and
forty-nine dollars which I feel like
it's kind of pricey for whatever this is
grand it's not a normal camera there's a
lot of tech built into this thing so I
guess that's why it's so expensive oh oh
oh it's very cute and man do I love this
teal color I think this might be a new
color that I'm gonna be getting into
this season there is a little button so
if you do want to take photos manually
you can just push that right there and
here's the little clip so it's kind of
like a little squishy plastic here so it
is what it says it is it's a Google clip
you can clip it on to things it's also
not meant to be a wearable camera so it
does work best if it's placed around
your house not on your body anything
else notice some instructions let's get
started I should probably look at these
because I don't know how to use it so in
case you guys didn't know it tells me
where the lenses
thanks for the diagram so there are
little LED lights that will pop up
whenever it is recording where's our
charging port there it is
yes PC I wonder if it's charged so I so
got this this was another little
addition this is the incipio tripod
so here's the problem think I might have
got tricked
there's no tripod with it apparently it
is just a protective case with tripod
mount so if you were thinking that this
came with a little tripod you'd be
deceived much like I was but don't worry
I've got plenty of tripods just I really
thought that it would have came up let's
set this up press the button okay it's
on oh there it is
clips looks for friendly faces your
camera automatically captures then it
sees a person or pet okay so we're going
through the updating process my camera's
up to date that was super quick I was
way faster than I thought it says my
camera is ready to use
twist your lens clockwise to start
capturing there's a little line right
there so when you line it up with that
dot can you see this can you see can I
see me can you see can we see ourselves
so it's already it's been taking
pictures and I didn't even know it so
here's the picture that I took this is
me hitting the shutter manually so it
takes 15 frames a second and it gives
you a 7 second clip video it's kind of
like burst mode when you take photos on
your phones and you can scroll through
and you can pick the one that you like
so if I'm like wow that's a good shot I
like that save it so right here this
will actually let you save jeff's you
can do an mp4 video a live photo or a
jiff which is pretty cool I've never
actually made a live photo before from
any other app other than my iPhone let's
take a look at that let's see it let's
see oh my so there's the picture that I
took oh this is one ice cream cheese so
there's the gist so that's my first test
of Google clips I'm gonna set it up
around the house while we film today
we're having a big shootin day we're
probably shooting like five or six or
seven or eight or hopefully ten videos
but I'm not sure if that's realistic or
not Nick's like so I'm gonna come back
in a few hours later and do kind of like
a little recap and see what we actually
have captured with the clips
[Music]
let's have several hours later I've been
looping this thing all around the
kitchen so it's got a bunch of different
shots some of me some of Nick some of me
my sister making videos some of the dog
so to show you some of the shots this
thing got today and after using it and
kind of looking through it's kind of a
neat little device yes granted in the
beginning I did say it's creepy it is
kind of creepy cuz it just sort of does
its own thing it really does have a mind
of its own and not only does it have a
mind of its own it has a developing mind
it's constantly learning okay here's
some clips this is from a future video
let's go in and we're gonna edit it and
it definitely got a good shot here I
tasted something that I made and it made
me actually discussed it so that's me
being sick saving the photo go into
motion save it as a jiff this is so
great oh this is what I was feeding my
dog dinner this is kind of weird to go
back and relive what I did today well
look at that making his meal
here's Jenna putting away the nor the
toys that we played with this is kind of
fun I'm this will be fun for like
parties I've got the camera in the cage
so here's Maddy I'm gonna save and save
up
nice to check out this is he looks super
cute
oh here's me trying to get a shot of
where I had the camera placement I'm
reliving my day this is so strange
oh my gosh this is crazy I think it's
balanced wow you're right look at that
that's it actually a very good job yeah
Wow I don't really into this actually
well I'm having a good time this is fun
so the total time capture is about three
hours then you have to recharge it so
throughout the day I just kind of
plugged it in here and there I don't
think I ever consistently had it fully
charged to 100% oh that being said I
feel like I got a lot of shots and I'm
not sure if this is anything that's
really that interesting but going
through this it was kind of cool to
relive my day through clips it was also
kind of cute like putting it in the cage
so I was able to see a little Maddy what
he was doing and get kind of some cool
pictures so I feel like this is
something that you're gonna be able to
get a perspective that you normally
wouldn't so what it does is it strings
together all of the photos into sort of
a seven second video and from there you
can create gifs you can create live
photos you can also choose stills from
there to save so this is really fun and
I can't wait to play with us a little
bit more I also would love to try this
at a party situation kind of have it set
up sort of as a photobooth so people can
just come up and if you want to press
the button you can and it can take some
shots because it is a I and it's always
learning faces that way it could learn
all of my close friends in one day so
I'm like guys listen you got to come
over this I've got this thing it's a
little camera and I need it to learn my
friends and they probably would not be
surprised at all cuz they're like okay I
just seen whatever we're not surprised
you were a camera on your head for six
months straight so this is a walk in the
park make sure you guys are following me
on Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
because I will probably be posting my
follow up there I'll definitely be
posting photos and videos from this
thing and I'll definitely definitely be
posting gifs gifs say it with me now
yes No get out no don't get out
you're filming stop stay please thank
you guys for watching I will see you
guys in my next video
make sure you guys subscribe like
whatever the heck everybody tells you to
do at the end of the videos just just do
that or don't do it I
even no but that's it I'm gonna go and
be creepy see you later
[Music]